اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم فدا باسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه احداث تقع منها
حجاج بيت الله الحرامي يواصلون اداء
المناسك في بيت الله الحرام وهذه الصور
المباشره تاتينا من مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللهم لبيك لبيك لا شري
ك لك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الحمد وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
البرهان يحذر من مؤامره وجوديه تهدد دوله
السودان ويدعو كل من يستطيع حمل السلاح
الانضمام للجيش لمواجهه من وصفهم
بالمتمردين ويعلن وقف اطلاق النار في اول
ايام عيد الاضحى واشنطن تعرب عن قلقها من
انتهاكات وقف اطلاق النار وتؤكد انه لا
يوجد حل عسكري للصراع وبيان غربي يدعو
طرفي القتال الى ضمان احترام حقوق الانسان
بيلاروسيا ساحه للحديث عن مستقبل مجموعه
فاجنر لوكاشينكو يكشف تفاصيل عرض قدمه
لقائد المجموعه يتضمن استضافتها وعدم
ممانعه انضمام مواطنين بيلاروس لها فنلندا
تعبر عن تخوف في الجوار الاوروبي وتطالب
بتعزيز الجناح الشرقي للنيتو وعقوبات
امريكيه على كيانات لصلاطها بمجموعه فاجنر
كيف تعزز ضغطها العسكري نحو بخمت وتشن
قصفا مكثفا على دونياسك الجيش الروسي يعلن
التصدي لهجمات في انحاء مختلفه من المدينه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يؤكد في مقابله
خاصه مع الجزيره ان الهجوم المضاد ما زال
في مراحله التمهيديه والبيت الابيض يعلن
عن حزمه مساعدات يقول انها ستدعم عمليات
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
حجاج بيت الله الحرام ينفرون من عرفات الى
مزدلفه بعد ادائهم الركن الاعظم والسلطات
السعوديه تعلن ان اكثر من مليون
وثمانمون المناسك في عوده الى اعداد ما
قبل جائحه كورونا
لا شريك لك
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات ازمه فاجنر خصوصا
بعد اخر الاخبار القادمه من بيلاروسيا حيث
اعلن الرئيس الكسندر لوكاشينكو في تصريحات
جديده بان بلاده قدمت عرضا باستضافه
المجموعه في قاعده عسكريه مهجوره وان منسك
لن تمنع مواطنيها من الانضمام الى فاقدر
هذا الاعلان اثر قلقا لدى الجارات
الاوروبيه لدى الجار الاوروبيه بالتحديد
بولندا التي طالبت بتعزيز الجناح الشرقي
للناتو كردي فعل على الامر والاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي هل سيشكل انطرقال
مجموعه فاغنر الى بيلاروسيا خطرا على
الدول الاوروبيه الاجابات جاءت على النحو
التالي
68% قالوا انه يشكل تهديدا في المقابل قال
32% انه لا يشكل تهديدا
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
البدايه من السودان حيث حذر الرئيس مجلس
السياده في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان من
ما وصفها بمؤامره وجوديه تهدد دوله
السودان ودع البرهان في خطاب له كل من
يستطيع حمل السلاح الانضمام للجيش لمواجهه
من وصفهم بالمتمردين كما اعلن وقفه اطلاق
النار في اول ايام عيد الاضحى
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلمه الكباشي المسلمي ما هي ابرز
الرسائل في خطاب البرهان عشيه عيد الاضحى
نعم الخطاب الذي انتهى قبل قليل لرئيس
مجلس السياده القائد العام للجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان اكد على ان البلاد
تتعرض لمؤامره تستهدف وحدتها وتستهدف
تفتيت نسيجها الاجتماعي وان هذه المؤامره
تقوم بها مجموعه تريد ان تستولي على
السلطه مستعينه بمرتزقه كما قال من جهات
كثيره وتريد ان تحقق مطامع شخصيه وقال ان
هذه المجموعه ارتكبت الجرائم شهد عليها
العالم وخاصه في مدن مختلفه في السودان
ذكر منها مدينه الابيض ومدينه الجنينه
التي قال ان الجرائم التي ارتكبت فيها
ترقى الى ان تكون جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الجرائم ضد الانسانيه وقال البرهان ان
الجيش السوداني قادر على تدمير هذه
المجموعه وانه
يشكر الشعب السوداني الذي وقف الى جانب
الجيش السوداني في هذه المعركه المتطاوله
ان الجيش قادر على حمايه البلاد وانه قادر
على تدمير هذه المجموعه المتمرده التي
قامت على على اطماع شخصيه كما قال
ودعى الشباب الى ان الشباب وغيرهم من
يستطيع حمل السلاح الى الدفاع عن بلده
سواء من بيته كما قال او من المواقع التي
يختارها في اشاره الى امكانيه ان يفتح
الباب الى مقاتلين
من المتقاعدين من افراد القوات المسلحه
والشرطه او غيرهم من القادرين على حمل
السلاح وهي فكره كان قد اعلن بها وزير
الدفاع قبل حوالي شهر قرارا بان يبلغ
القادرون على حمل السلاح الى الجهات
القريبه الجهات الرسميه العسكريه القريبه
ولكنها لم تنفذ اشار البرهان ايضا في
خطابه الى السنه الرابعه الى الذكرى
الرابعه للثوره ابريل التي اطاحت بحكم
الرئيس عمر البشير وقال ان
محمد حمدان دقله كما اراد ان يختطف هذه
الثوره واراد ان يذهب بهذه الثوره ليحقق
مملكته الخاصه كما قال ولكن الجيش هو
الاحرص ان والمتوافق مع اهداف هذه الثوره
واهداف شباب هذه الثوره بالانتقال الى
نظام حكم مدني ديمقراطي وهو الذي يمكن ان
ينفذ هذا هذا هذا الانتقال الجيش هو الذي
بشباب الثوره يمكن ان يؤسس لانتقال الحكم
المدني الديمقراطي البرهان اشار الى شقر
الشعب السوداني هذه الوقفه وشكر المدن
القريبه من الخرطوم لاستضافتها النازحين
من الخرطوم الى هذه المواقع المختلفه
وكذلك شكر الدول المجاوره التي فتحت كما
قال حدودها للسودانيين هذا هو مجمل
المجمل النقاط الهامه التي وردت في خطاب
ايضا وقفا لاطلاق النار خلال ايام العيد
هل اتضحت ماهيه هذا وقف اطلاق النار هذا
ولكم يوم المقصود به
لم تتضح ولكن يبدو انه ليوم واحد على
الاقل يوم واحد ليوم العيد ليتاح للناس
فرصه ان يؤدوا مناسك العيد ويؤدي صلوات
العيد ويعد مناسكها وطقوسها المختلفه ولكن
هذه النقطه بالذات لم ترد فيها توضيحات
غير الاعلان عنها في ذاته طيب اذا ما
قررنا هذا الخطاب بظهور سابق للبرهان ما
الذي يمكن ملاحظته
الملاحظه الاساسيه ان البرهان في في
الزهور السابق كان ظهورا بين قادته كان من
الواضح ان الهدف منه دفع القوات دفعا
معنويا وانه يريد ان يقول انه وسط قواته
وانه يدير المعركه بنفسه في تلك الفتره
بين قواته وانها يريد ان يعزز معنويات
الجنود الذين يقاتلون وان يرسل رساله الى
الشعب بان الجيش قادر على حمل هذه
المسؤوليه وانه هو وسط جنوده يؤدي هذا هذا
الواجب اما هذا الخطاب فقد كانت فيه
مؤشرات واضحه جدا الى نتائج هذه الحرب
التي لا تزال مستمره الى اكثر من شهرين
وهي اشاره فيها الى البنيات التحتيه التي
تحطمت بسبب ما سماه هو التمرد على الدوله
في هذا المتمردين على الدوله واشارك ذلك
الى الاوضاع الانسانيه التي في تلك المدن
التي تاثرت تاثرا بالغا بهذه الحرب واشار
الى ايضا دفعه معنويه جديده في انه
الشعبانيين شكرا لك للمسلم الكباشي مدير
مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من الخرطوم حول نفس
الموضوع ينضم الينا من الخرطوم معتصم عبد
القادر حسن المستشار في الاكاديميه العليا
للدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه سيد
المعتصم سيد معتصم
ما الذي لفت نظركم في هذا الخطاب اليوم
للسيد البرهان عشيه عيد الاضحى
السيد البركان تحدث في هذا الخطاب وهذه
الغابه عنها طويله
نعم هو اصدرات سابقه تتعلق بموصله كبري
السياده ولكن اليوم خاطر الشعب السوداني
هذا
المنصبنه الجيش السوداني ما يلتقي هذا
الخطاب وانا اعتقد انه سيكون في هذه الحرب
الدائره ضد التمر باخوات الدعم السريع انه
ادعى الشباب الى حمض هذا ما كان يبحث عنه
المواطنين
السودانيين كانوا يريدون ان يحملوا السلاح
بطريقه قانونيه دفاعا
سواء كان في اخلاص السودان لان هنالك
محاولات الان لفتح الجبهات هنالك اشتعال
وانا اعتقد انه اشتعال نتيجه لاسباب ماديه
هنالك بعض الفصائل في بعض الحركات تم
اغراءها ماديا ودفعها لشد الاطراف في
السودان وشغل الحكومه السودانيه عن
المعركه الاساسيه
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يتم فيها دعوه
الشباب وكل من يستطيع لحمل السلاح ما
الخطوره التي يمكن ان يشكلها يعني تصرف من
من هذا القبيل الا يمكن ان يؤدي الى ما
يحذر منه العالم وهو حرب اهليه سوداني في
وجه سوداني اخر
نحن الان في حرب اهليه نحن الان في حاله
حاله من
الان الصرطوم مستني يهاجمون في منازلهم
ولا يستطيعون حتى الخروج للشوارع خوفا من
الطائف فانا اعتقد ان هذه الخطوه كانت
ضروريه للمواطنين للدفاع عن انفسهم وكانوا
ينتظرونها في المره السابقه كانت الدعوه
للمعاشين وكانت محصوده حتى ان الجيش
السوداني يستفيد من كل المحاكم ذهبوا
اليهم والحكمه الان يمكن لاي سوداني اي
دافع عن عرضه او ان يدافع عن امواله
ايضا كيف سيحصل السوداني على الاسلحه من
اين سيحصل عليها وكيف يمكن ضبط عمليه
انتشار الاسلحه في ايدي السودانيين
انا اقتراح منتشر في يد الدعم السريع
المتمرد
فيما ذكرت لك من انتهاكات ولكن السوداني
عنها مقتنع تماما انه يمكن ان تحمل القوات
المسلحه وينضم الى اي وحدات عسكريه ومعلوم
ارقامهم الوطنيه ويمكن ان يسجل هذا السلاح
ويمكن ان يسترد بعد نهايه المعركه لا خوف
لا خوف يعني يستخدم هذا السلاح مستقبلا في
اي عمل ضار الدوله
السوداء السودانيين وانضباط الشباب
السوداني وحرصهم والاخلاقي والوجداني على
عدم انتهاك الاخرين
انا اعتقد ان هذه المساله سوف تعجل
هذه الازمه
قوات الدعم المتمرده في في مساله رقايه
وغايه الخطوره لان المواطنين الان يمكنهم
الصيامهم بكل سهوله لانهم موجودون في
المنازل موجودين في الشوارع غير موجودين
في مناطق في مناطق عسكريه ومعسكر معتصم
عبد القادر حسن المستشار في الاكاديميه
العليا للدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
كنت معنا من الخرطوم شكرا لك ينضم الينا
من الخرطوم الباشا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
سيد الباشا كيف قراتم خطاب البرهان في هذا
التوقيت
والتحيه لمشاهدين قناه الجزيره
حقيقه ما قرانا هذا الخطاب تاكد لنا تماما
فشل البرهان بحسم المعرفه مع قوات الدعم
السريع عبر الجيش وهو الان يدعو الى يدعو
الشباب الى حمل السلاح لصب الزيدي عن
النار والاشتعاله السودان
اشتعالا على ما هو عليه الان ويريد ان ان
تصبح هنالك حرب اهليه شامله في كل انحاء
السودان لان هذه الدعوه هي واضحه جدا انه
عجز تماما وفشل هذه
السودان من حرب اهليه بالفعل الان
الحرب العالميه تشتغل فيها هو ايضا فيها
البراءه ان احنا كلنا نتوقع من هذا الخطاب
ان يبشر الشعب السوداني ان هنالك ابو
شريات وهنالك حوار وهنالك يعني اتخاذ ضرار
لانهاء هذه الحرب لكن ان نسمع الان ونحن
مقبلين على عيد الاضحى والشعب كله يعاني
من هذه الحرب نسمع انه يدعو الشباب لحمل
السلاح هذا فشل واضح جدا وهذا يؤشر الى
احتراق السوداني يعني هذا الخطاب هو خطاب
يعني يعني يؤكد فشل البرهان في اداره هذه
الحرب ويؤكد تماما يعني
يعني
قد يكون الشعب الامل في حل حل
الا يمكن ان نقرا هذه الدعوه بان السيد
البرهان يتمتع بشعبيه على الارض تسمح له
بالدعوه الشباب لحمل السلاح من اجل الوقوف
الى جانبه
يا استاذي الكريم ابو اكد لك تماما كما
يتمتع البرهان بشعبيه هنالك منقسم حول هذه
الحرب هنالك من يؤيد الدعم السريعين الجيش
وهنالك من يقف في الرصيف يعني يعني
يشاهد هذه الحرب لا الشعب السوداني الان
جله لا يريد ان تستمر هذه الحرب يريد ان
تتوقف هذه الحرب حتى تتوقف معاناه الشعب
السوداني شعب السوداني الان يعاني حتى
البنيه التحتيه الذي يعني تحدث عنها
البرهان هو الذي دمر البنيه التحتيه
بطيرانه وبضربه الطائش باستخدامه
للمواطنين ولكل المواقع الاستراتيجيه
للدوله ومن دمرها يعني لماذا لماذا
الاستمرار في هذه الحرب ماذا يريد البرهان
من هذه الحرب ماذا يريد ان يصل هل يريد ان
يستمر
السيد البرهان مسؤوليه هذه الحرب بينما
يستمر او تستمر قوات الدعم السريع ايضا في
اشتباكاتها وفي اطلاق النار
رواه الدعم السريع
وسمعنا بالامس خطاب من قاعده الدعم السريع
وبشر الشعب السوداني ويلتزم فيه بهدنه من
جانب واحد لمده يومين اللي هي يوم
يوم عيد الاضحى المبارك
عن وقت لاطلاق النار من جانب واحد ايضا
اذا الحل
الشباب الشباب
ماذا ماذا يريد هل القوات المسلحه غير
قادره ان تحسم هذه الحرب
الان نريد ان تق
ف هذه وصلت الفكره الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
كنت معنا من الخرطوم
هذا واعربت واشنطن عن قلقها من انتهاكات
وقف اطلاق النار واكدت انه لا يوجد حل
عسكري للصراع اما فيما يتعلق بالتطورات في
دارفور فقد ادانا بيان امريكي بريطاني
نرويجي الانتهاكات الواسعه النطاق لحقوق
الانسان في دارفور وادع البيان قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني لضمان احترام حقوق
الانسان بدورها حذرت الامم المتحده من ان
ياخذ النزاع في الاقليم طابعا عرقيا
[موسيقى]
بينما يكتنف الغموض مستقبل شركه ايفاجنر
اعلنت بيلاروسيا وصول قائد المجموعه
وعرض الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو
استضافه قوات في احدى القواعد العسكريه
المهجوره في بلاده مع اثار مخاوف لدى
الغرب من اقترابها جغرافيا من حدود اوروبا
في غضون ذلك اقر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بان الدوله مولت فاجنر خلال سنه
واحده بما يعادل مليارا ومئه مليون دولار
هذه الصور التي تعود لمساء يوم السبت كانت
اخر ظهور علاني عندما غادر المقرات
العسكريه في رستوف ولم يعلم من حينها مكان
وجوده اخيرا اعلن الرئيس البيلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشينكو ان قائد فاجنر وصل الى
بيلاروسيا
بوتين تزامن ذلك مع ظهور الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وسط عسكريين وهياكل الامن
الروسي الذين حياهم على دورهم فيما سماه
اخماد التمرد
[موسيقى]
كان لعزمكم وشجاعتكم ووحده الشعب الروسي
باكمله دور كبير في استقرار الوضع اولئك
الذين اقحموا في التمرد راوا ان الشعب
والجيش ليس الى جانبهم الانتشار السريع
والدقيق ولهيئات قوى الامن سمح باعتراض
اخطر تطور محتملا للاوضاع في البلاد وحاله
دون وقوع ضحايا من المدنيين الرئيس الروسي
كشف ان الدوله انفقت من ميزانيتها 86
مليار روبل اي ما يعادل مليارا ومئه مليون
دولار لتمويل شركه فاجنر بوتين اقر في
خطابه بمقتل طيارين اثناء مواجهتهم لتقدم
قوات فاجنر باتجاه موسكو وهو ما اكده
بريجوجن بالقول ان رجاله اضطر لاسقاط
طائرات مروحيه هاجمتهم بينما كانوا في
طريقهم الى العاصمه ولم ترد اي معلومات
رسميه عن عدد الطيارين الذين لقوا حتفهم
ولا عن عدد الطائرات التي اسقطت
حاله الصدام بين الجيش الروسي وفاجنر تطرح
علامات استفهام بشان مصير هذه المجموعه
العسكريه اكد بوتين انه سيفي بوعده
بالسماح لمقاتليها بتوقيع عقود مع وزاره
الدفاع او العوده لعائلاتهم او الانتقال
الى بيلاروسيا حسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
فان التحضيرات جاريه لنقل المعدات
العسكريه الثقيله لفاجنر الى وحدات الجيش
الروسي
قبل وصوله الى
ان لوكاشينكو عرض ضمن وساطته السماح
لفاجنر بالعمل في اطار قانوني وهذه اشاره
لمستقبل التمركز الجغرافي للشركه وقد
اكدها الرئيس البيلاروسي في تصريحات قال
فيها ان بلاده ستستفيد من خبره مقاتل
فاجنر وانه لن يمنع المواطنين
البيلاروسيين من الانضمام الى المجموعه
التي عرض استضافتها في احدى الثكنات
العسكريه المهجوره في بيلاروسيا يثير هذا
الانتقال لمقر قياده فاجنر مخاوف معلنه
لدى الغرب باعتباره يقربها اكثر الى حدود
اوروبا وذاك ما عبرت عنه بولندا بوصفه
بالاشاره السلبيه وقال رئيسها انه يريد
تعزيز الامن على الجناح الشرقي للنيتو كل
هذا يبقي باب الاسئله مفتوحا بشان الادوار
التي قد تلعبها فاجنر مستقبلا
قبل قليل قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان قرار
الرئيس بيلاروسيا الترحيب ببريغوجين يظهر
انه يتخذ خطوات لصالح الكريم
ان تركيز القوه في موسكو يفسر سرعه تقدم
فاجنر في البلاد واضاف زولوتوف ان الحرس
الوطني سيحصل على اسلحه ثقيله ودبابات
للمره الاولى مشيرا الى ان هناك الامر مع
الرئيس بوتين وقال زولوتوف انه لا يستبعد
دنوع اجهزه استخبارات اجنبيه في محاوله
التمرد المسلح
ينضم الينا من موسكو ليونيل
الضابط السابق في الاستخبارات الروسيه
والمدير السابق للمعهد الروسي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومن وارسو مرسين مدير
السياسات في برنامج مستقبل الامن التابعه
لمؤسسه جلوبل للابحاث وعضو المجلس
الاستشاري للعلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
البولنديل ابدا معك سيد ليونيت سيد ليونيت
من الواضح بان الاجراءات التي اتخذها
الرئيس بوتين لم تؤدي في النهايه الى
تفتيت مؤسسه فاجنر بل انتقلت من موسكو او
من روسيا ومن قياده الجانب الروسي لها الى
بيلاروسيا التي تؤمن لها مقر ولا تمانع ان
ينضم الشعب البيلاروسي اليها
مجموعه
في النتيجه في نتيجه اعمال الرئيس
والاداره الروسيه في الواقع
كشركه موحده من عشرين الف شخص سوف تختفي
من الوجود وسوف يسافر لبروسيا مجموعه
صغيره من الذين يريدون ان يعملوا مع
فريجوجن والاعداد المتوقعه هي حوالي 5000
شخص الباقيه اما انهم سيوقعوا عقود مع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه والبعض بداوا بهذا
والاخرين سوف تسحب الاسلحه منهم
ولن تتوجه كميه كبيره الى بيروسيا ولكن
لديها كل الامكانات لاعاده تاسيس نفسها
القائد موجود والعناصر ايضا حيث قال
الرئيس البيلاروسي بانه لا يمانع ان ينضم
اعضاء شعبه الى فاغنر او ابناء شعبه
هذا هذه المساله اخرى اذا كان هناك مجموعه
التي
تتشكل من بعض الالاف واذا سمح السيد
لوكاشنك
بالتعبئه قد يقوم بتعبئه بعض السكان
المحليين في بيروسيا وهذا شيء من الصعب
استبعاده ولكن هذا لن يكون قرار الرئاسه
الروسيه اذا كان لوكاشينكا قد قرر ان يقوم
بزياده اعداد هؤلاء الجنود تحت اداره
فقد يسمح بالتعبئه بالنسبه لنا يمكن ان
يقدم الرئيس لوكيشنكو على ذلك دون موافقه
الرئيس الروسي وهو حليف الاساسي
سيد ليونيت
[موسيقى]
انهم ليس عليهم ان يقتربوا ليبيا طيب ما
هنا اتحول للسيد مارسين سيد مرسين ما الذي
تخشاه بولندا من انتقال بريكوجين الى
بيلاروسيا
فولندا خائفه على وجه الخصوص من مكان
تواجد بريكوجين
ان هدف وجود حتى الان غير واضح
لا نعرف اذا سوف يتمكن فعلا من اعاده
تشكيل هذه القوات المسلحه التي يديرها سيد
مرسين عندما يقول الرئيس البولندي انتقال
مجموعه فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا اشاره سلبيه
بالنسبه لنا ويطالب بتعزيز الامن على
الجناح الشرقي للناتو الا يعبر هذا الكلام
عن خشيه لدى بولندا من فاقنر
السبب ليس
سبب الخوف والقلق بل الحاجه الى التصدي
لروسيا العدائيه والضفه الشرقيه الشمال
الاطلسيه جابوا تعزيزا لقد حصلت بعض
التعزيزات توردت الى الضفه الشرقيه منذ
اعتداء روسيا على اوكرانيا والان هناك
اعداد من جنود الناتو اكثر بكثير من ذي
قبل في بولندا في دول البلطيق وساره لدينا
حلفاء جدد لان
فنلندا والنرويج انضمتا الى او تريدان
الانضمام وسرطاج جزءا اساسيه من الضفه
الشرقيه هذا كله بسبب بوتين هو الذي اطلق
الحرب على اوكرانيا لانه اخاف من
ان تحتويه
ولكن الان زاد عدد عدد اعضاء الجمل
الاطلسي
امن بهذا
عفوا سيد مارسين يعني هنالك تصريحات ايضا
للرئيس الليتوانيه يتحدث عن ان انتقال
السيد بريكوجين الى بيلاروسيا انما يعني
يجعل من هذه المؤسسه او هذه القوات اقرب
الى زعزعه الاستقرار في شرق اوروبا اعود
معك الى ما قامت به الخارجيه الامريكيه من
اجراءات وفرضت عقوبات على كيانات قريبه من
فاجنر كيف تقيمون هذه الخطوات او هل هي
كافيه في هذا التوقيت
لا اعتقد ان الاجراءات المتخذه حاليا
والاجراءات الاخرى
المرتبطه بفاكنر
والاطراف الروسيه والبيلاروسيه كافيه
اعتقد ان النيتو يجب ان يعزز وجوده واتخاذ
اجراءات اضافيه لمنع هؤلاء من تدمير
السلام في اوروبا لا شك في ان مجموعه
فاغنر
كلها تمثل عنصرا لانعدام الاستقرار تساهم
في تعزيز النزاعات اشخاصهم مجرمون لديهم
سوابق جرميه ليس لديهم
فعلا كانوا قوه
قتاليه فعاله لروسيا ويمكن ان تصير كذلك
سوف يفعلون ما يامرهم به سيد اليونيد
الجانب الروسي بعض الصفقه التي جرت مع
فاجنر اكد بان حركه التمرد حسب ما يسميها
انتهت ولكن عندما يقول رئيس الحرس الوطني
ان الحرس سيحصل على اسلحه ثقيله ودبابات
للمره الاولى الا يشير بان الخطر لا زال
قائما ان لم يكن من بريجوجين فمن غيره
الحرس الوطني
وقواتها تقوم بعمليات كثيره في مواضع
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه وفي الجبهات وفي
الخطوط الاماميه ودون الاسلحه الثقيله سوف
يكون هذا صعب على سبيل المثال الحرس
الوطني تدافع عن حدود بيل جراد وبالاسلحه
الناريه ان تقف ضد
التخربيين او الهجمات الاوكرانيه على
مديننا وقرانا هذا سيكون صعب
لذلك سوف تقدم لهم الاسلحه الثقيله للحرس
الوطني وهذه الاسلحه سوف تستخدم في
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
الفرق الكثيره يجب ان تحصل على هذه
الاسلحه وهذا قرار سليم في السابق قبل عام
2004 الحرس الوطني والقوات الداخليه كان
لديها اسلحه ثقيله ثم كان هناك تغيير ات
عسكريه وسحبت هذه الاسلحه منهم ويجب ان
تعود لهم لان الحرس الوطني هما لاعبين
مهمين في الدفاع عن حدودنا ضد العدوان
الاوكرانين اذا كان الامر كذلك لماذا لم
يتم تحقيق مطالبهم الا بعد تحرك فاجنر
التمرد كان شيء غير متوقع وكان على شكل
مؤامره وكان من الواضح ان جزء كبير من
قوات واجنا يجب ان ترحل الى
الى حتى تدعم الامن حتى تكون درعا امنا
ولكن ما حدث ان التمرد بدا وهذه القوات
قوات باغنر تم شطبها من القائمه وسوف تمحى
من نظام الدفاع المسلح الروسي لن تكون
موجوده في هذه المنظومه لذلك استبدالها من
الممكن ان يكون فقط عن طريق الحرس الوطني
التي تعتبر ليست اقل من قوات شكرا لك
الضابط السابق في الاستخبارات الروسيه
والمدير السابق للمعهد الروسي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من موسكو وشكر
موصول للسيد مرسين اذا برفسكي مدير
السياسات في برنامج مستقبل الامن التابعه
لمؤسسه جلوبسك للابحاث وعضو المجلس
الاستشاري العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
البولندي من وارسو
تداعيات المشهد المتعلق في فاجنر غير
بعيده عن اوكرانيا والحرب فيها حيث باتت
تكثف القوات الاوكرانيه عملياتها في الشرق
وتحديدا نحو بخموت ودونياسك وفي وقت تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه فيها انها حققت تقدما
في باخمت قال الجيش الروسي انه صد هجمات
الجبهه التي عادت ليشتعل رمادها بعد اكثر
من شهر من اعلان مجموعه فاغنر والقوات
الروسيه سيطرتها عليها اللواء الثالث في
الجيش الاوكراني نشر صورا قال انها من
معارك جنوبيه المدينه بين الجانبين من
مسافات قريبه وجدد قال انها لجنود الروس
بينما نشرت قوه حرس الحدود الاوكرانيه
مشاهد من مقاله انها معارك عنيفه ضد
القوات الروسيه في باخموت 17 اشتباكا
قتاليا وفق المتحدث باسم قياده عمليه
منطقه الشرق في القوه الاوكرانيه في اتجاه
المدينه خلال 24 ساعه ادت الى مقتل العشره
من الجنود الروس وتدمير اليات ومنصات
اطلاق الصواريخ
واضافه الى بخموت قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قوتها وصلت عمليتها
الهجوميه في اتجاهات بريديان
وحققت تقدما في عدد من الجبهات بينما تركز
الهجوم الروسي خصوصا على محوري
حيث دارت اشتباكات وقصف متبادل في مناطق
عديده ودوت انفجارات في مدينه كرامات عقب
رسل تحليق صواريخ وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بالمقابل تحدثت عن صد قواتها عشر هجمات في
دنيات ودمرت مستودع ذخيره للقوات
الاوكرانيه في افديفكا كما اسقطت سته
تعرضت بدورها لعمليه قصف صاروخي وفق
السلطات الاوكرانيه ثلاث منها كانت
بصواريخ من طراز اس 300 استهدفت منطقه
دروشكوفكا ولان نالز دنيتك بتطوراتها
المتلاحقه حصه الاسد من المواجهات فخرسون
في الجنوب استهدفت بدورها بقصف اوكراني
طالب 5 سلطته المواليه لروسيا تحدثت
بدورها عن وجود معارك على جبهتها مشكله
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم
واصطام مخاوف السلطات
الاوكرانيه مما سمته هجوما ارهابيا محتملا
في محطه
وغير بعيد اعلن مسؤول شبه جزيره القرم
التي ضمتها روسيا تعرض خطوط السكك الحديد
للاضرار في منطقه كروسكي من دون ان يسقط
ضحايا فكما يجري على جبهات اوكرانيا
الشرقيه والجنوبيه اما في مكان اخر فوق
بحر البلطيق فتدريبات تكتيكيه بطائره
مقاتله لاختبار الجاهزيه لاداء العمليات
القتاليه على مدار الساعه وفق دفاع
الروسيه ولحراسه المجال الجوي
وتلك تبدو رساله روسيه على ان عينها يقظه
ومستعده للتعامل مع اي طارئ رغم انشغالها
بجبهات اوكرانيا وتداعيات التمرد مجموعه
فاجنر
وعقل وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اليك في
مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره قال ان قواته ما
زالت في المرحله التمهيديه من هجومها
المضاده اضاف ان الجيش الاوكراني في طور
التحضير وان كل جبهه ستكون لها مناوراتها
الخاصه على حد تعبيره واكد ريزنكوفا ان
لدى حلف الاطلسي نيا جديه لقبول اوكرانيا
في الحلف
في هذه المرحله بالتحديد بالامكان القول
اننا ما نزال في مرحله الاعداد فقط قواتنا
المسلحه تقوم بتنفيذ بعض العمليات
والمناورات اضافه الى عمليات نزع للالغام
في مناطق وجبهات عده هم يقومون بالمهام
المنوطه بهم وفقا للخطه الموضوعه من رئاسه
الاركان وسنرى تطور ذلك كما اتمنى خلال
الايام القادمه
وفي اطار دعم اوكرانيا في هجومها المضاد
اعلن البيت الابيض ان حزمه المساعدات
الامريكيه الجديده ستدعم عمليات الهجوم
المضاده وقالت نائبه المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض اوليفيا دالتن ان الحزمه ستعزز
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه للتصدي
للهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا حيث نواصل الوقوف
الى جانب شعبها ضد الغزو الروسي الوحشي
الحزمه تتضمن قدرات اساسيه لدعم عمليات
الهجوم المضاد وستعزز الدفاعات الجويه
لمساعده اوكرانيا على التصدي للهجمات
الصاروخيه كما اكد الرئيس بايدن لنظيره
الاوكراني يوم الاحد فاننا سنواصل دعم
اكياس وهي تدافع عن سيادتها ووحده اراضيها
ضد العدوان الروسي
ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويد
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يقول ان قواته ما
زالت في المرحله التمهيديه ما هي الخلاصات
التي يمكن استنتاجها من هذه المرحله
واستخدام هذه الخلاصات لتحديد ماهيه
الهجوم المضاد
يعني كثر الحديث حول منذ تقريبا شهر بدا
الهجوم في الرابع من الشهر هل هو الهجوم
المضاد هل هي المرحله التمهيديه
وتحدثنا كثيرا
وقلت ان هذه هي تمثل المرحله التمهيديه
لجمله اسباب ولديها العديد من المهام
المحدده اهم الاسباب ان حجم القوه التي
اشترك في العمليات العسكريه
لا يتجاوز في الحد الادنى 30% من حجم
القوه المخصصه اي ثلاثه الويه من اصل تسعه
او خمس القوه بقياسا الى مركز دراسات
الحرب الذي قال بانه يوجد لدى اوكرانيا من
تسعه الى 15 لواء المهام بصوره عامه كانت
هي اولا
عمليات جسر النبض استطلاع بالقوه تحديد
نقاط الضعف في الدفاعات
الروسيه هذه العمليه التمهيديه لوق فايز
هل تعطينا اي مؤشرات على شكل وطبيعه
الهجوم المضاده والاهداف اهداف هذا الهجوم
من اين سيبدا هذا الهجوم ابرز محاور هذا
الهجوم
الان تعطي اشارات لكن لا يمكن اخذها
بالمطلق بانها اشارات دقيقه قد تكون ضمن
اطار عما يطلق عليه عمليه الخداع
الاستراتيجي وكيف ذلك اولا هذه الاختراقات
التي حدثت في ثلاثه مناطق في جبروجيا في
دونيسك
واخر شيء في خرسون عند عمليه عبور نهر
وبالتالي اي نجاحات يمكن تطويرها اي بمعنى
اخر اذا ما نجحت في تطويق
موت اذا استعاده السيطره عليها ووصلت الى
نهر بخموتسكا الان ستصبح هي جهد رئيس اذا
ما نجحت في منطقه ذابروجيا ووصلت الى تكمك
ستكون هناك بديل اخر ولكن الاخطر من
المقاربتين
لم يتم بحثه حتى هذه اللحظه منطقه
زبالوجيا انا في قراءه المبدئيه للخارطه
اقول ان هذه النجاحات يمكن تطويرها وفي
حال واجهت عقبات سيفاجئ الجميع ان الجهد
الرئيسي لن ياتي من هذه المناطق سياتي من
خرسن خاصه بعد تدمير السد لماذا لان حجم
الدفاعات الروسيه قليل تم نقل جزء كبير من
هذه القوه بعد بعد تدمير السد وتم نقل
باتجاه
اصبحت خاسره رخوه تعتبر اكثر المقتربات
التي تقود الى عمق الزجاجه مدخل شبه جزيره
القرم اذا اذا نجحت الخيارات في
او فيزا بروجيا توك ماك قد تحول الى جهد
رئيسي اذا تعثرت سيكون الاحتياط
الاستراتيجي جاهزا للاندفاع بمناوره
التفاف عميقه من منطقه خرسون باتجاه شبه
جزيره سكر عندما يقول وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان الجيش الاوكراني في توضيح
التحضير وان كل جبهه ستكون لها مناوراتها
الخاصه
بالمفهوم العسكري ما الذي يعنيه هذا
مناورات خاصه لكل جبهه
لماذا لان هذه هي
المناوره تعتمد على طبيعه
التوظيف الدفاعي للقوات الروسيه الان اذا
ذهبنا شمالا الى منطقه ازيومان التي تهاجم
القوات الروسيه التي تدافع القوات
الاوكرانيه اذا ما نجحت باحتواء الهجوم
ستتحول للتعرف سيتم اتساع الجبهه وستشكل
خطوره في عمليه اختراق عميق وانتفاف
باتجاهي وسط دونيس اذا ذهبنا الى باك موت
كما قلت لك اذا ما تم السيطره على فخمه
ومن ثم سوليدار ستنفتح الارض بسبب السيطره
على شبكات الطرق وطرق الشريعه وبالتالي
يتحول اتجاه المناوره كذلك في منطقه خرسون
في منطقه اذا وصلوا الى توك ماك هذه ستكون
بيضه القبان في العمليات العسكريه شكرا لك
لوقفايز الدويري كنت معنا من عمان
الحرب في اوكرانيا والحديث عن تنقلات
مجموعه فاجنر معطياتنا عديده باتت تدفع
الدول الاوروبيه لتعزيز ترسانتها العسكريه
اخر الاخبار كانت من فرنسا التي دخلت
سباقه تسلح لتطوير صواريخ فرد صوتيه
باجراءها اول تجربه لصاروخ اسرع من الصوت
خمس مرات
هذا الخبر واجواء سباق التسلح في القاره
الاوروبيه سيكون محور نقاش لنا في فقره
المتابعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
يواصل حجاج بيت الله الحرام ان فيره من
صعيد عرفات الى مشعر مزدلفه حيث يصلون
المغرب والعشاء جمعه تاخير ويقضون ليلتهم
هناك استعدادا ليوم النحر وكان الحجاج قد
وقفوا في صعيد عرفات وادوا صلاتي الظهر
والعصر قصرا وجمعا وقد اعلنا وزير الحج
والعمر السعودي توفيق ربيعه ان عدد الحجاج
لهذا العام بلغ اكثر من مليون و 800 الف
حاج اتوا من اكثر من 150 دوله
لبيك اللهم
جبل عرفه والزمان يوم عرفه حيث وقفت جموع
الحجيج من كافه الاعراق في محطه النسك
الثانيه منذ صبيحه التاسع من ذي الحجه
استمع حجاج بيت الله الحرام الى خطبه جامع
نمره وقاموا بعدها صلاتي الظهر والعصر
جمعا وقصرا وتلهج الالسن بالدعوات
والابتهالات
[موسيقى]
بل هو ايات من ايات الله بالكون
قال الله تعالى ومن اياته خلق السماوات
والارض واختلاف السنتكم والوانكم ان في
ذلك لايات
للعالمين وان مما تتابعت النصوص على
تاكيده
الامر بالاجتماع والمحبه والتالف والنهي
عن التنازع والتفرق والاختلاف اكثر من
مليون وثمانمائه الف حاج يجمعهم مكان واحد
ليوم واحد رغم تعدد لغاتهم واعراقهم
وانتماءاتهم وتعدد انماط حياتهم في حشد لا
يتكرر شيوى على هذه البقعه المقدسه التي
لا تتجاوز مساحتها 11 كيلومترا تتم ادارته
بسلاسه فضلا من الله
ورحمه منه يسر لنا ان نكون ضمن حجيج هذا
العام من السودان رغم الظروف اللي كانت
حاصله في بلادنا لكن يسر الله عز وجل
العقبات وذل للصعاب
وتمكنا ان نكون بين ركب الحجاج ملبين
وحاجه حلوه عن الحج والله ربنا ان شاء
الله يوعد كل مشتاق ان شاء الله وربنا
يتقبل منا جميعا من جميع كل واحد حضر
الحجه ربنا يتقبل منه ومننا ومن امه محمد
جميعا نشكر الله ونحمده على انه شرفنا
بهذا المكان وطبعا ربنا يعودها علينا مرات
كثيره ويرزق اولادنا وجميع خلقه بهذا
المكان وحج بيته الحرام ربي يتقبل
دعائنا وان شاء الله ربي ينصر جميع الامه
الاسلاميه
تميل الشمس الى الغروب ولا يزال الخشوع
والسكينه يغشى يعني افئده الحجيج في اقدس
واطهري بقاع الارض مشهد مهيب هنا في مشعل
عرفات ورغم حراره الشمس المرتفعه لا احد
هنا يستعجل الغروب فهذا هو اليوم المنتظر
والاحباب الذين اوصوا الحجاجه بالدعاء
كثيرون ولافده والعقول لا يشغلها الا نيل
المغفره والقبول بدر ربيعان الجزيره من
امام جبل الرحمه مشاري عرفات
بالعوده الى خبر تجربه الفرنسيه الاولى من
نوعها لصاروخه فرد صوتي في اطار سباق
محموم من عده دول لامتلاك هذه التكنولوجيا
العسكريه المتطوره يمكن ان تصل سرعه هذا
النوع من الصواريخ الى اسرع من الصوت بخمس
مرات او ما يعادل
600 الف كيلو متر بالساعه او 6000 كيلومتر
بالساعه اطلق الصاروخ الفرنسي فيماكس من
مركبه تسمح باخذ مقاييس دقيقه وحلق في
جنوب فرنسا واستنادا لتقرير سابق لصحيفه
التايمز فان بلدان اعده بدا تتسابق لتطوير
مثل هذه الاسلحه التي تعتبر الصين
والولايات المتحده وروسيا الاكثر تقدما
فيها كما تقوم دول اخرى كالمملكه المتحده
واستراليا وفرنسا والمانيا بالبحث في هذه
التكنولوجيا وللتصدي لهذه الاسلحه تقول
تايمز ان الدول تطلع ايضا الى تطوير او
تتطلع الى تطوير انظمه مضاده للاسلحه
الفرد صوتيه تكون قادره على مواجهات
الصواريخ القادمه من تداعيات حرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا تطوير الترسانه العسكريه للدول
الاوروبيه ورفع ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع بشكل
لافت وتحسبا للاسوء وفق تقرير لمعهد
ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث السلام فان واردات
الاسلحه الى اوروبا تضاعفت تقريبا في عام
2022 مدفوعه بعمليات تسليم ضخمه الى
اوكرانيا التي اصبحت ثالث اكبر وجهه لها
في العالم
وكان المستشار الالماني اكد ان بلده سوف
تمتلك اكبر جيش اوروبي تقليدي في الناتو
بفضل الاستثمارات الضخمه التي اقرها عقب
تخصيص اثنين في المئه من الناتج المحلي
للموازنه الدفاعيه لتصبح ميزانيه الانفاق
العسكري ما بين 70 الى 80 مليار يورو
سنويا كما طالب الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل
ماكرون باعاده تقييم لقانون البرمجه
العسكريه مع تاسيس قاعده صناعيه تكنولوجيه
للدفاع الاوروبي والفرنسي وتخصيص 400
مليار دولار بين عامي
20140 للانفاق العسكري
اما بريطانيا فقد اعلنت الاستثمار في
القتال الجويه مع زياده الانفاق الدفاعي
الى اثنين ونصف في المئه من الناتج المحلي
بحلول عام
2030 ينضم الينا من باريس الجنرال
المتقاعد من هناك اذا ينضم الينا دومينيك
ترانكو الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك يا سيد
بدايه اهميه هذه التجربه بالنسبه
لفرنسا وكيف ستنعكس على ترسانتها العسكريه
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الدعوه
اولا يجب الا ننسى انه في اوروبا فرنسا
تمتلك السلاح نوويه وبالتالي قوه الرادعه
لدفاع عن دولتنا امر ذات اهميه كبيره
ولنكون راجعين يجب ان نتمتع
بانظمه اسلحه متطوره لذلك كانت فرنسا
من السباقين في اطلاق هذا الصاروخ الفرد
صوتي الذي تم اختباره الاسبوع الماضي هذا
متوقع في السنوات المقبله طبعا ولكن بسبب
الوضع لقد تم التسريع في اختبار هذا
النظام لهذا تم اختباره سريعا طيب اذا ما
قارنا مستوى فرنسا في هذه التكنولوجيا مع
المملكه المتحده واستراليا والمانيا كيف
يمكن ان نصف المستوى الفرنسي في هذا
الاطار
اذا كنا نتحدث عن استراليا او المانيا لا
تمتلكان اسلحه نوويه وبالتالي يمكننا ان
نناقش فقط مقارنه بين الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده وفرنسا هذا عذرا السيد
ولكنها تقوم
ببحث في هذه التكنولوجيا تكنولوجيا
الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه قامت فرنسا بهذه
التجربه ولكن بالنسبه للدول الاخرى مدى
تقدم فرنسا في هذه التكنولوجيا
اتحدث عن المملكه المتحده لان دول اخرى
ليس لديها سلاح نووي ولكن بالنسبه الى
الصواريخ الفرد صوتيه فان استخدامها هو ان
تحمل القوه النوويه هذا هو الهدف الرئيسي
من استخدامها ولكن اذا استخدمنا او جربنا
صاروخا مماثلا يمكن ان نستخدمه لاهداف
متعدده يعني
يمكن ان يحمل اسلحه فرط صوتيه تستخدم برا
او بحرا بحسب معرفتي بهذه التجربه الى حد
علمي الولايات المتحده قد اختبرتها
روسيا تمتلكه الصين وفرنسا تختا بيرانه
والمانيا ايضا تختبر هذا النظام طيب سيد
يعني هنالك تطوير للترسانه العسكريه بشكل
عام في اوروبا وزياده ميزانيه وزاره
الدفاع المانيا على سبيل المثال اثنين
بالمئه من الناتج المحلي بريطانيا اثنين
فاصل خمسه زياده ميزانيه وزاره الدفاع الا
يؤخذ من
مجالات اخرى مهمه للشعب الفرنسي والشعب
الالماني والشعوب الاوروبيه بشكل عام الا
ياتي على حساب اشياء اخرى
انتم محقون كافه الدول الاوروبيه تزيد من
ميزانياتها وانفاقها الدفاعي بسبب الحرب
في اوكرانيا حاليا ونحن نستعد في حال كان
هناك حاجه للتصدي للجيش الروسي وهذا ما
يبرر الارتفاع في الانفاق الدفاعي في
فرنسا هناك نقاش او حصل نقاش في مجزء
الشيوخ وتم الاتفاق على الموضوع في
البرلمان ومجلس الشيوخ ونحن حذرون بشان
ضروره
تخصيص
الموارد الضروريه
للميزانيه الدفاعيه وفي السنوات الخمسه
المقبله نتحدث نتحدث عن 400 مليار ليس
اكثر لاننا لا نريد ان نتوقف عن تمويل
باقي القطاعات ضمن الموازنه في المانيا او
بولندا مثلا يمكنهم ان يعززوا هذه النفقات
اكثر
في التقرير كان هناك صور
للقوات البريه
والمدرعات طبعا هذا امر ضروري يجب زياده
الميزانيه كافه الميزانيه الدفاعيه
الاوروبيه تم تعزيزها لاسيما للدول في
النيتو ولكن ايضا في كافه انحاء اوروبا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه الجنرال
المتقاعد كنت معنا من باريس
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد كل عام وانتم
بخير الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]